so this is me shout out to them focus
they do not only PI data they actually
sponsor a lot of the miracle work think
it's done everywhere alright so are
there any books on Julia you have lots
of books you can get love them online
for free more or less numb focus alright
here we are we're in Julia and here's
Julia over here in Jupiter as well as is
the R for R okay so I think there's zero
our talks so I feel like I'm a head
somewhere right but I've been working
with pipe off for quite a while too so
and I started with a port Ram so I go
way back in terms of the merits let's
see if this works
there we go alright so this is not for
beginners the learn deserve yes there is
here we go probably doesn't help much in
the second row okay this is a very cool
book Anna we have time I'm going to be
looking into it okay there's a talk
given at Julia con julia calm by Michael
and it's really a great talk and it has
lots of examples of Julia built right
into the textbook alright so and does
anyone know who is not one of the
creators of Julia in this picture it's
key know it but the other four are the
creators these are actually the
cofounders of juliek Julia computing so
the founders the creators of the
language two years later decided to form
their own company alright so there are
blogs out there they're pretty good the
bottom one is going to be a little more
commercial of course the top one has
some really cool kind of stuff mostly in
Julia
online courseware plenty of that this is
from Cape Town University and it uses a
jupiter notebook to present the course
so it works quite well and it's free
unless you want a certificate which
costs a little bit okay so this was two
weeks ago and it was a great turnout
lots of stuff happening Fernando Perez
mister ipython himself gave a keynote
and here's some of the talks David
Sanders a great tutorial and the title
moving towards a version 1.0 right
Juliana right here is at 0.6 that just
came out four or five days ago June 27th
and before warned there are some things
that broke from oh five two oh six the
promise is though that nothing will
break going from six to one point zero
which is the next scheduled release
nothing will break in the sense that if
it isn't already deprecated now it won't
be deprecated later all right but all
the deprecation warnings will be taken
out and a few more talks machine
learning of course and homomorphic
encryption which is very compute heavy
right nice talk and there are many more
and these are now available on video ok
so there's a use case from a couple
years back the FAA next time you fly
keep this in mind try to have positive
thoughts about software there's a great
website about the ten major failures of
the physical world caused by software
the REO five rockets a great example
but that's another talk okay so let's
look at some of the differences between
Julia and Python on the Julia or website
they also give you differences between
Julia and MATLAB Julia and C++ but this
is probably the most relevant here are
the things that either love or hate
about Python you either love or hate
about Julia possibly at the same time so
indexing starts at one rather than zero
and this piece here which for those of
us who are used to close set notation
feels a little more natural to include
both two and three as the last element
okay so the last element here is
included here is the next to the right
one left then are we all know about from
the way that slicing works at ranges
okay and you don't have any negative
indices the very cool - one - two -
three part in the Python where you have
int is a keyword all right so the end
also gets used in the blocks right there
is indentation not so much right patient
really doesn't matter white space here
and there does matter
you know you sometimes cannot put it put
a blank space between between things um
you'll discover that
and you does the same sort of thing with
many languages do now if it thinks
there's more to come
it'll wait if the things it's done it's
done so if you put your plus sign of the
second line it won't it won't look for
it alright so I hope this is invisible
to people in the 10th 10th row which is
what I GERD this for so here we have a
small difference in how the modulo
operator works it comes down to here you
have minus 1 and here you have plus 2
remainder versus modulo the results are
pretty much the same for positive
numbers but it can be a gotcha if you're
depending on a particularly behavior so
here is version 0.6 point oh and three
point six one so there are some
differences between Julia and two point
seven you're pretty much on your own for
that and I think by now okay so this is
the fun one
not only the Python change integer
division there's always been this double
slash available in Python right what
says I really want you to do integer
arithmetic here the difference is that
python will give you that integer result
for the double slash whereas julia will
give you a rational and you can see it
operating over here we have 7/4 plus 4/7
I may have put an extra blank in there
just for visibility but the two slashes
should go right next to each other and
you get 65 28
which is a useful for some applications
right if you really need rationals you
get them automatically
now you can convert rationals the
integer this is part of the very
convoluted intricate type system that we
all deal with one way or the other
a duck typing or not it's hard to avoid
caring at sometimes just what you have
so there we can convert a rational
number to an integer I trying to make
sense but you can't really not all cases
get taken care of for you automatically
so for doing integer division and one of
the numbers is a float julia is going to
squawk so apologies if the red on blue
is a little too contrasted back there
but don't let you know that there's an
error and it gives you some suggestions
as to what you might might use so
there's this notion of multiple dispatch
which means that you can run Julia
without caring about types at all or you
can care very much why we do want to
care very much generally poor
performance for time performance just
like numpy and number and psyphon look
underneath the hood and try to really
take advantage of what's known about the
machine architecture well Julia lets you
do that as well the other time you'll
care is when it comes to precision
numerical work especially when is doing
some sort of calculations involving say
a Taylor series or differential
equations rounding error starts become
significant
so one of the packages I'll have a quick
shot of it later on
it's called interval arithmetic by David
Sanders so if you really care about
knowing how accurate your answers are
based on the significance you you put in
to begin with of our tools available
okay so here's another small difference
the carat Python sees it as a shift
right to to the cubed you just you get
weird I'm talking about - it's a bit
operation right so in Julia
it's the exponentiation
so this is where porting codes gets a
little tricky if you put in the double
star it's not going to work if you copy
code back and forth and it doesn't give
you a syntax there it doesn't mean it's
right so you need to actually test your
code and have you use cases that really
exercise the of the features that's just
like with the modulo operator
okay now this one right remember Julia
doesn't have a continuation character so
that backslash and gets put to good use
in being inverse division so eight back
flash - if that was a video moment there
he thought kind of a shaking head there
it gives you 2 over 8 and because as a
single slash is going to convert it to a
float and so
to overrate yes is indeed 0.258
over to invert it's going to give you
the same result
alright you say do I really need that
well turns out it comes in handy so a
couple other things to look at are how
conversion happens julia like python has
a ripple that's pretty nice ripple that
incorporates a lot of the features that
we've gotten used to it ipython is the
others also runs inside of jupiter so
you can do similar kinds of explorations
so here's one that seems a little
irritating right if you can't take the
int of an array you go ok there's
something going on time terms of types
sure you know you can understand that
then we get an error in exact error so
in the repple if I type the question
mark which I didn't do there but I did
do after julia prompt you don't see it
and automatically converts it into into
a help and so i typed in the air and
sure enough it says type conversion
cannot be done exactly alright well
that's because you have at least four
ways of doing conversions this is the
notion one of the underlying principles
of julia is no your new bearings know
what you start with know what you want
to get know what your tolerance for for
failure for air for precision are and if
not it's going to let you know that you
don't know okay
so here you have four different
approaches
okay another difference is in how the
the plus equal minus equal operators
work so this has to do with how of the
binding of names is done like variables
labels overriding a raise these parts
become important when you have
situations where you have huge amounts
of memory at state and so if you can do
things in place it's often much better
in place meaning in place in real memory
fewer - ships and what cash its you also
worry about things like rows and columns
what the real layout gets underneath
alright so here's a couple of
side-by-side examples and this one shows
some of the differences the
idiosyncrasies of each of each language
once you understand Python well this
seems to be perfect reasonable on the
right once you understand giulio L is
perfectly reasonable on the left
alright where you know what happens to
the updating when you have shared lables
lable sharing the same underlying value
now again languages are easy is the
concepts that are difficult right all
right so here we have another difference
that involves how default parameters are
handled so with the rand function that
would be note 3 a judgment call in terms
of what you want your function to do
that's important that you know what you
want to do to begin with
so in Julia this will always be
evaluated every each and every time the
function is called it's different than
Python where it would get evaluated once
and that becomes the default throughout
you know one used in the function okay I
may try to do a little live demo but
those always seem to have glitching so
I'm just going to run through this and
we'll do what every we can live later on
okay one more change Python it's a
two-letter I'm not quite sure that I
like the idea of using two letters and
you certainly cannot put a space in
between here and here
let's now SOEs a little bit of an
aggravation of times because you want to
have readability right of your code but
these are what the requirements are all
right so the world is divided into
people who go like this and people who
go like this right depending on how your
data is organized that's how you want to
organize your code right that's the
bottom line
which way is numerically going to be a
most interest is it going to be through
along the rows or through the call right
you want to reduce cache hits as much as
possible all right well you're looking
at arrays that are not nearly a thousand
by a thousand there may be 10,000 by
10,000 mm right this starts become a
very challenging problem
okay so Julia also has notion of
horizontal and vertical and transposes
and then these little dot operations as
well
so let's do a couple of examples now
there's not any difference here between
the comma and the semicolon this in this
context but we can see that the space
gives me a 1 by 3 array and the commas
or semicolons gives me a 3 by 1 and sure
enough these buts a double equal they're
no hard to see but it is and the types
like these are raising defaulted to in
64 I could have specified that B is yes
sir question the the - oh it should be
the number of dimensions yes
now because it's an array not a right so
that first dimension right okay let's
see okay so here we go
and there's a more convincing case of a
being a two-dimensional array right
there the three by three this is the one
by three and here we have this backslash
again all right and this is where it
becomes more than just a trick it's a
useful trick so what I'm trying to do is
solve the system of linear equations a
3x3 write a times x equals y and it says
nope not going to work so we have
tab-completion and over here I see
something like determinant and I plug it
in here now there's a lot of stuff that
comes pre bundled in with with Julia so
while there are the notion of importing
modules or packages and Julia we will
add packages and then use the package
it's a little different than Python in
that case in this case determinants
built-in anything to do with basic
matrix operations like inverse trace
determinant is already there you don't
need to do it anything extra for and
here's our problem is that the
determinant is 0 so I'm going to go
ahead and just change one element there
now I have a nice happy determinant I'm
good to go and I still have a problem
right ok that's because Y is pointing
the wrong direction right go along Y to
go like this or Y to go like this right
all right so that apostrophe at the very
end
there's a mouse in right here
this apostrophe is shorthand for
transpose and now I get my solution
right so it's nice and nice and
compacted that and you can build on
these so multiplication of arrays right
there's a one by one right multiplying
it this way this way I guess or both
plying it this way right you know how it
works with matrices when you multiply
vectors yeah you have your choice
there's a whole library I would have to
check to give you an answer for this for
this instance but it's one of the things
that Julie has been taking they have
like 30 or 40 different methods that you
can use with almost every operation to
make them smarter so here we're
multiplying our matrices creating a
random random array and invert getting
the eigenvalues so one of the creators
of Julia is Alan Edelman and he faculty
at MIT and he's basically king of the
eigenvector and so that's part of what
informs a lot of what went on in in
developing julia okay so now there's
Julia box which is part of Julia
computing it's kind of like anaconda
continuum analytics where they have a
free free set up a mini Conda and then
they have their commercial enterprise so
Julia box is Julia online and so here we
go some examples from that
and again my try to just play with us a
little bit towards the end okay and here
we have those of you like looking at
Linux a little more of that all right so
I'm going to run through a bunch of
these I'm just going to give you a
flavor of what what's out in terms of
Julia Land
there's also Juneau which is built on
top of Adam
now is your editor of choice right
without sublime or if you want to do
some more of an IDE right VI Emacs
whatever floats your code so this is all
run inside of atom with the Giulia so
the package system in Giulia whether I
think there's was the numbers of 1400
last time I checked they're over a
hundred thousand packages in Python so
it's good and bad a thousand fifteen
hundred sorry still too many to claim
expertise on or even awareness of what
each of those those do one thing that is
interesting is that they're instant
testing built in to the here we have a
fail so this is six months ago Julia
just got released version six just got
released the week ago so I once expect
all packages to pass and the passing is
only as good as the testing so you can't
just rely on what it says pass yeah
actually I see what it is that it is
passing the breaking breakage between oh
five and oh six for people who've
invested like say the FAA which it has
this big aircraft collision avoidance
system that's written and Julia they
probably aren't going to port 206 that
quickly like these things move at the
speed of government here's the interval
arithmetic deep-learning bloom filters
were probabilistic lots of stuff out
there and gas why is one of the packages
that was written specifically for Julia
and I can get plots out there fairly
nicely this is the iris data that
everybody refers to okay gallium
debugging I have another doesn't take
much to get complicated enough that you
hope there is a debug around and there
is and there's a great talk I love the
hand gesture there that's key know one
of the major contributors core
committers
but not one of the creators of Julia and
this is from last year so it's fairly
recent okay
Python has of this function right if you
want to see what's underneath
you know what the byte code is so duty
will give you what the native code looks
like as well and this will be of
interest once you start worrying about
having a piece of code run overnight
right as opposed to can I get it in an
hour or if I can get an hour can I get
it in a minute instead right so when you
start getting into performance issues
fish you'll probably go down this this
road as well
okay so packages get added to Julia it
calls to get removed from Julia so this
is from your workspace so think of it as
what condom might do with a pip
would you do a pip install you haven't
really been anything with the codes yet
you're not using it but you are prepping
the system for it and so jump does
mathematical modeling all sorts of cool
things so she wanted to add the jump
package which isn't built-in it's going
to go out there and fetch it so you need
an internet connection most likely
and if you look at the Giulia bloggers
log he goes through a use case of
solving the fish riddle very cute so
that's me let me do a couple of other
things while we're here the first thing
is I wanted to figure out what I was
going to talk about and so just like
this full screen here we go and oops no
no I don't want to picture this really
right there let's try that ah I have one
of these giveaway hide your camera thing
there we go all right so yeah I know
this is backwards that's because I'm
left-handed
okay I borrowed a right-handed Mac by
mistake okay so this is the my buying
map of what I needed to talk about right
the IDE and you know the type system and
the dispatch and high performance
computing yeah
so being the only julia talk Bantu it's
not going to be so this is just a type
system all right this is the abbreviated
version of everything that goes on in
terms of julia cleverness so you're
welcome to reverse reverse the image and
the user as you like that's
[Music]
close us away
okay so let's just do a little bit of a
tour as to what's going on here so if
you're going to work with Julia you want
to figure out why get very friendly with
the Julia website
and here's a just an automatic demo that
comes on the Giulia blog showing you how
they might work in Adam and let that run
for for a little bit
let's just let that run on the side
there okay and that's if I can actually
get this Julia box tutorial to run for
me
if I can connect here
connecting to the kernel so this is
Jupiter you're all familiar with uber
and you can see that there's lots of and
you may or may not be talking let's see
if that works okay very good
embedded tutorials inside of the
documentation about types more about
types a nice post about the difference
between this is in the Haskell log about
the difference between Julia and Haskell
in terms of the type system to recommend
ah you really want to know about MATLAB
differences our differences C++
differences from julia right it's great
for anyone who wants to port okay here
are the notebooks from the online course
that's available so if we look at say
the type system right
so this is not live within the way that
Julia box would be budget on github and
you can you can download it pretty
pretty easily it's a nice little course
and it's intended to be a course for
true beginners not people who are coming
from Python are coming from are people
are just coming to coding might be a
little ambitious even in learn Python
the hard way and the introduction that
says now this is for people who are a
though out of code
with nice little cheat sheet upstairs oh
this from the course given that MIT
believed everything on earth still valid
in oh six
the essentials the whole notion of
what's equal or isn't so Julia and
JavaScript do you have something in
common
the triple equal sign right is in other
words writing good Julia functions well
performant is the first word type stable
is the second and lunchable that's in
the eye of the beholder yeah
lots of stuff on the Giulia of computing
blog is not just marketing materials
they do have some pretty good conduct
tree material this is a set of slides
sorry let me skip over this for now so
flux this is a contribution from the
community to do machine learning in
Karis like like fashion not connected
okay let's see
I think my best shot is to come in here
and maybe start over again now they
think with Julia boxes you need to sign
up for it and have a password there's no
charge
you have a nice tutorial on the oh five
highlights hopefully they will have one
on the oh six highlights fairly soon and
here it is actually you can run live in
Julia box okay so here's what happens
when you add a package it's clothing
right so it's bringing it down from
github now the first time that you use a
package it's going to be compiling it
but bit more intense than what importing
a module is in Python there's some work
that gets done of course with an import
with using and actually compiles it to
to your machine context
let's try restarting this guy here okay
GPU arrays right that's another aspect
of high-performance computing is without
you can tap into your GPUs here's a talk
given just a couple weeks ago by David
Sanders on the 1.0 story again it's also
has the intuitive notebook available so
again very useful look what to look at
some blog stuff here let's see if we
have little kernel here we go are we
live so just like a recognizer the
asterisk is telling you that it's
thinking I think I'm going to have to
just restart
how're we doing on time okay let me try
doing something else here
okay so here is
okay so here is a local notebook that I
have okay
so I got this off of one of the julia
posts and see oh he's still alive here
oh there we go okay so this is our local
my machine there's a nice little
function
now because I already added the package
I already used the package once it's
much faster right
using Julia on small sets works pretty
well what is still slow is doing the
importing right because it's doing
compiling so since all the companies are
going to use a hundred billion times
it's going to do it all up front once
and so it's going to be a time a time
penalty on that let's see how far we can
get here so somebody came up with a
mathematical formula that when you plot
it it replicates the formula it's called
tupper's cuppers equation and it's just
a clever toy trick
so you can see you get a lot of
information that you may or may not want
so here we are package update oh that's
going to take a while it's going to rely
on the internet and so that will wait
also a little okay so let me know here
it is now one of the challenges of doing
very large projects is sometimes your
underlying code changes and you don't
want to restart everything so there are
some modules out there packages out
there that will let you reload packages
again you know use with caution
alright that's going to cook for a bit
let me just see if I can minimize this
here we go okay okay so here is the
textbook that I mentioned earlier it's a
great it's pre-publication I'm one of
several many reviewers of this if this
is something that appeals to you should
be an email as well the idea is that you
read it in exchange for commenting on it
okay so Michael Kaufman therfore he's at
Stanford now he was involved with the
FAA project at Lincoln labs using Julia
and what's really nice about this is all
the julia quote that is embedded
let's just go down
here we go okay so those of you who are
really into gradients right
so this is the math that most people are
happy to step around when they're doing
machine learning so here it is in in
Julia and this character had all the
Greek characters alpha betas you can
access those by just putting in a
backslash and in the tab and that's if I
can quickly demo that try that okay so
any last-minute questions I think it's
time for lunch
more or less so they're right there you
saw me create a and a hello there no yes
I'm just curious about the what is the
interoperability story for Python and
Julia well I think it's similar to the
interoperability stored between Python
and R it exists it's possibly a bit more
robust because of the tightness that
julia has with Jupiter ok so while Julia
is informed by MATLAB and our studio
it's really in the Jupiter camp so the
kernel is much further along there are
you can use PI call pretty easily in
Julia and there are a lot of rappers
available so you'll actually can access
map plot lib and things of that sort of
curly in a fairly straightforward
fashion okay anything else quick one
here thank you
given that package management is done
from within julia itself what is the
support for environments
what kind of run like a like a virtual
ends kind of thing ah I don't I I don't
know offhand
[Music]
I don't know I know that the package
system has there is a talk actually a
con about the upcoming package
management system but that's an
excellent question
you know I have a dozen convent
environments for Python I just run run
Julia in one single environment of my
box you know typically it's going to be
doing to their work on a cluster right
you're but still you're going to want to
have some sort of environment you know
sandboxing available
anything else okay so I think I got
about 1/3 of the way through the
material I would like to have touched on
but I'm happy to answer questions and
let's see if I'd put my contact info up
here again oops
it's very briefly lunch is starting
outside cell so Frankie need but you
guys can take the room for questions
you're not blocking anyone so feel free
to take your time and thanks again thank
you
[Applause]